dans un royaume qui tu roules sous les
lois pas de se couper justin rêve de
liberté
je vais être un chevalier il te faut une
quête
mon grand père avait une épée je vais la
rapporter à la maison maintenant
le héros le plus improbable de tous les
temps je veux qu'on entraîne devra
trouver le courage d'accomplir sa
destinée et pour cela nous avons choisi
un classique un dragon
non
plus bas
oui
demain ce pays aura un nouveau roi je
les couronnes cyr héraklion à l'épée tu
vas te mâchouiller est recraché aussi
sec
là je suis prêt j'adore ton esprit une
acolyte si tu ne rejoint pas mon arrêt
alors l'affrontera
là haut
c'est l'apocalypse est à nos portes pour
relâcher la jeune fille le début d'une
nouvelle ère une nouvelle ère pour de
nouveaux héros
créature des flammes
entendez la voix